-The President is lying
about former special counsel
Robert Mueller's
Congressional testimony.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Yesterday, the man who oversaw
a two-year investigation
into a criminal operation
by a foreign government
to interfere
in a presidential election
testified before Congress
on national television,
and right off the bat, he made
headlines when he said this.
-Did you actually totally
exonerate the President?
-No.
-Under Department of Justice
policy,
the President
could be prosecuted
for obstruction-of-justice
crimes after he leaves office.
Is this correct?
-True.
-Man, he was quick on the draw
with that answer.
It's like he's been
waiting two years
for someone to ask him
that question.
"And do you have
the handcuffs picked ou--"
"Yes!"
Over the course of seven hours,
Mueller laid out details
of a criminal attempt
to interfere
in a presidential election,
a campaign that openly welcomed
and encouraged that interference
in a series of lies
and potential attempts
to obstruct justice by
the President and his aides.
In normal times, that
would be incredibly damning,
and yet we're all
so numb to everything,
people are acting like
because Mueller didn't come out
and say the words,
"Trump is guilty,"
it wasn't a big deal.
But what were you expecting?
Did you think Mueller was
gonna smash through the wall
in a monster truck called
"The Detrumpulator"?
Mueller's report, in itself,
is already damning.
We just got to see him
explain it on national TV.
Yes, he occasionally stumbled
or had to consult the report,
but it's over 400 pages
with footnotes and citations.
If you asked me under oath
about something I said
in "A Closer Look" yesterday,
I'd have to consult
the script, too.
"Let's see.
I'd like to refer you
to appendix c, subsection 43b,
where in "A Closer Look"
we play the clip
of Elizabeth Warren
saying the words...
-Crazy [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Also...
it's pretty rich when the people
who complain that Mueller
stumbled over details
in a 400-page report
are the same people
who are totally fine
with Mr. Details over here.
-This will be a plan where
you can choose your doctor.
This will be a plan
where you can choose your plan.
And you know what the plan is.
This is the plan.
-I mean, it's very easy
not to stumble when you're just
using the same five words
over and over again.
But give him something trickier,
like the word "lawmakers,"
and then see what happens.
-He has worked
in both houses of Congress,
advising law-markers.
[ Laughter ]
-"The law-marker, of course.
Being the Sharpie
that every judge uses
to write out
their legal decision.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, law-marker."
Of course, Mueller's
very straightforward claim
that he could not exonerate
the President
comes after months of Trump
claiming unequivocally
that the Mueller Report
completely and totally
exonerated him.
-There was no collusion
with Russia.
There was no obstruction
and none whatsoever.
And it was a complete
and total exoneration.
-"No collusion, no obstruction.
Complete and total exoneration.
Keep America great."
-Total exoneration.
Complete vindication.
-And, hey, you know, in this
case, you got to believe Trump
because he definitely
read the report, right?
-I have not read
the Mueller Report.
I haven't seen
As far as I'm concerned, I don't
care about the Mueller Report.
-I mean, I'm not surprised
he didn't read it,
but it's jarring when he
just comes out and admits it.
He's like a guy at a book club
who's had a few glasses of wine
going, "But I guess
if I'm being totally honest,
my favorite part
of 'Fifty Shades of Grey'
was the cover,
because I did not read it.
[ Laughter ]
And, also, we are out of pinot!
By the way."
So, for four months,
Trump has been saying
the report completely
and totally exonerated him.
How does he feel now
that Mueller said explicitly,
on national television,
that he did not exonerate Trump?
-There is no such a thing.
He didn't have the right
to exonerate.
And, you know,
it's very interesting.
People mention exoneration.
That was something
where he totally folded
because he never had
the right to exonerate.
-Donald Trump has a tell.
Whenever he goes, "You know,
it's very interesting..."
he's about to lay out
some five-star bull [bleep].
So Mueller made clear that
he could not exonerate Trump
because that was basically
his only option.
Mueller couldn't just
straight-up indict Trump
because of Justice Department
guidelines
that say you can't indict
a sitting president.
So instead,
he basically had to say,
"We can't exonerate
the president.
Now it's up to Congress."
But then Republicans
weirdly tried to claim
that Mueller that didn't have
the power to claim someone
was either exonerated
or not exonerated.
One Republican Congressman
even made a big show
of that point using props,
but Mueller wasn't having it.
-Mr. Mueller,
does the attorney general
have the power or authority
to exonerate?
What I'm putting up here
is United States code.
This is where the attorney
general gets his power
in the Constitution and
the annotated cases of these,
which we've searched.
We even went to your law school,
'cause I went to Case Western,
but I thought maybe your law
school teaches it differently.
And we got the criminal-law
textbook from your law school.
Mr. Mueller, nowhere in these,
'cause we had them scanned,
is there a process or
description on exonerate.
There's no office of exoneration
at the attorney general's
office.
There's no certificate
at the bottom of his desk.
Mr. Mueller,
would you agree with me
that the attorney general does
not have the power to exonerate?
-Uh, I'm going to pass on that.
-[ Chuckles ] Oh.
It's such a bummer
when you bust out
all your books,
and the other guy doesn't care.
I feel so bad for the staff
that had to get all that stuff.
I feel like this isn't
gonna work out
the way you think it will.
"Oh, trust me!
When he sees the books,
his head will explode!"
I'm gonna be like,
"Do you remember this one
from your law school?!"
[ Laughter ]
Of course,
no matter what Mueller said,
nothing was going to stop Trump
from declaring victory,
which is what he did on his way
to an event last night
in West Virginia, when he
once again stopped by reporters
for his usual chopper-adjacent
Q and Yell.
-There was no defense
of what Robert Mueller
was trying to defend,
in all fairness
to Robert Mueller,
whether his performance
was a bad one or good one.
I think everybody
understands that.
I think everybody understands
what's going on.
This has been a very bad thing
for our country.
And despite everything
we've been through,
it's been an incredible
2 1/2 years for our country --
the administration,
our president -- me.
-Oh, you! You're the president!
Well...
That explains a lot.
Later, Trump was asked
about Mueller's assertion
that Trump's aides had lied
during the investigation,
and Trump both denied
that Mueller had said that
and also claimed
the reporter herself was lying
by asking the question.
-Let me just tell you something.
I know
You always have a question.
You mean my
White House aides lie?
What about his aides?
What about Mueller's aides?
He didn't say that at all.
You're untruthful
when you ask --
You are untruthful
when you ask that question.
When you ask that question,
you're untruthful.
And you know
who else is untruthful?
You know who else is untruthful?
His aides.
-Why does anyone even
ask him questions anymore?
It's like continuing to put
dollar bills in a jukebox
that only plays
"Achy Breaky Heart"
no matter
what buttons you press.
Also, can we go back to this?
-Let me just tell you something.
I know.
You always have a question.
-Yeah.
She always has a question.
She's a reporter!
When the mailman shows up
at your door, do you say,
"Oh, let me guess. An envelope?
[ Laughter ]
Would a pizza kill you,
mailman?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Mueller was also asked yesterday
about Trump's various attacks
on his investigation,
and his answers were very clear.
-When Donald Trump called
your investigation a witch hunt,
that was also false, was it not?
-I'd like to think so, yes.
-Well, your investigation
is not a witch hunt, is it?
-It is not a witch hunt.
-When the President said the
Russian interference was a hoax,
that was false, wasn't it?
-True.
-Now, compare that to how Trump
reacted just a few hours later.
-There was no defense
to this ridiculous hoax,
this witch hunt that's been
going on for a long time.
And everybody knew
it was a hoax.
WikiLeaks is a hoax
just like everything else.
And all of those problems
having to do with crime
were the biggest hoax of all.
It was a witch hunt,
a total witch hunt.
We did nothing wrong.
The answer's very simple.
Nothing was done wrong.
This was all a big hoax.
-Okay, I know
you watched the hearing,
but did you listen
or did your aides
secretly dub over
Mueller's lines
with Sean Hannity saying
nice things about you?
-Hannity: The witch hunt
is officially over.
The Mueller Report is out,
and the President
of the United States
has been totally
and completely vindicated.
-The President and his allies
have immediately started lying
about yesterday's hearings
because those hearings laid out
in clear and unequivocal terms
the story of what happened,
and that story
is incredibly damning.
At this point,
it's up to Congress
to do something about it.
They could either stand by
and do nothing
or they can impeach...
-Our president -- me.
-This has been "A Closer Look."